[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
i know it's wrong
but i don't care
[Music]
is
[Music]
eyes for your eyes
[Music]
think about it later
think about it later
the damage is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
eyes for your eyes
[Music]
[Music]
think about it later think about it
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well we wanted to do a historical top 50
of
uh chess players of sort of all time and
to
to do that we are using um the
statistics by
jeff sonax who has created a site called
chessmetrics we've gotten some help from
frank hofmeister who is a well we know
jesus story and but then
we have still kind of added our own
touch and
it's always going to be subjective and
there's simply there's no correct answer
i hope you guys
enjoyed and i hope you agree with every
single ranking because usually when you
public lists
what could go wrong who would disagree
with anything
but yeah it's been it's been fun and i
hope you like it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody good afternoon we would
like to welcome you
on the eighth altibox norway chess event
for the final round
we are here excitedly waiting the last
rounds fight together with vladimir
kramnik
who we are together the hosts and
commentators for you during this event
uh good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls brothers and sisters
let's make the last effort today
to follow this great tournament
and we are here for you again
uh and yesterday so let's see who is
playing today and what are they hoping
for
the participants of of those games
well yeah we have the final round in
some way we could say it's not so
interesting because we have a winner
already magnus carlsen
won the tournament after round nine but
at the same time we love
chess we love to to watch these guys
playing and fighting
and so let's see what will be the
pairings for today
magnus will be playing against levon
aaronyan which can be a huge battle i
believe because uh
it will be depending on the opening how
it will be
and how the levon will have his fighting
spirit also i guess
the other pair will be fabiano caruana
against the young
norwegian ariane tari who had a lot of
lessons in this tournament
but i'm sure he still gets all his lost
energy for the last round
and he would like probably to avoid yet
another lesson yesterday
probably he would like uh wants to be to
become a teacher yeah
that's my guess well he had the chance
yesterday against levon aronian very
much so that must have been a very
painful
game for him even though he did not lost
the
classical game but he was so winning and
he had such an opportunity to win
against the best
one of the best players in the world but
he missed that
and we have the third pair which is
extremely interesting because right now
alireza
is on second place he's going to be
playing with the white pieces
against young christophe so what is the
standing let's see
we just said that magnus won already the
tournament but there is a huge fight for
the second place
because we have alireza firoza for
second place 15 and a half
we have level naranjan on 14 and a half
fabiano caruana on 14 and those three
players
any of them can get to second place and
there is a lot of
money at stake as well while magnus
carlsen collected already the first
prize which is 40
74 75 000 the players will receive their
money
in norwegian kron the approximation of
the price is 74 000
the second price will be 39 000. while
the third prize
is only or not only but comparing to the
39 it's only 24 000
and fourth prize is 19 000 so we may see
some of the moves which will be very
costly moves right what do you mean i've
i've made quite a few in my life here
but
um frankly as a professional chess
player you don't really think about it
yeah
i i guess yeah i mean you shouldn't you
shouldn't think about it because
i think that let's say fight for the
second place
i'm sure that for all of them it's not
fighting for additional money but
fighting for uh
you know for a very big position because
the first place of magnus carlton was
of course not uh obligatory but it was
uh
let's be frank expected so basically
it's
uh it's about fighting for the first
place
among mortals yeah so i mean for
so well i'm joking of course but it's a
very very
prestigious place also in this
tournament that's why i believe
it's it's going to be very interesting
for me it's
it's also i mean not only that uh it's
not chess is not
only and not definitely not mainly about
places yeah so for me this round is as
interesting as
as uh if the first place wouldn't be
decided yet
and uh yeah so let's as i understand the
situation
okay um i think that uh second if you're
talking about second place
livona needs to win uh
with black uh i mean the the classical
game to have a chance to
take the second place yeah uh uh
which will not be easy but maybe he can
try it
and then um let's say uh the same goes
for
uh fabiano karana but he has white
against uh
arientari so his task is a bit a bit
easier than
than levon's task and
if he wins uh he's getting three points
then he needs uh uh
furuja not to win with white so if ruja
is winning today with white he's second
i mean the classical game he's second in
any case
and but if he wins let's say it's a draw
and he wins in uh
armageddon games then i think they share
with fabian karana second third place so
it's quite complicated
uh situation so it's clear that uh to
pretend
uh for the second place arunyan and
karwan
must win and
firuja can afford to win in thai break
so that is uh that is the mathematics of
today
and let's come to let's move to chairs
yeah from
yeah we just see the start of the games
uh
in the magnus game they just played the
first move but we have few moves in the
other games
fabiano played e4 e5 knight f3
it's going to be some rye lopez i guess
yes so well fabiana has a lot of
experience in royal lopez much more than
aryan but who knows i mean it's still a
very solid opening and uh
even if uh tari is not doing well in
this tournament i guess his
his mood is is not
great but uh still beating him
is is uh you know not going to be easy
and so let's see let's see what is
fabiana is thinking now i think he is
choosing i mean he thinks whether to
play italian with bishop c4
or to play roy lopez bishop b5
uh i don't know why he thinks because i
guess he should have
i mean he should have prepared it before
but sometimes you know
you hesitate till the last moment yeah
that happens
and then you start to think uh at the
very beginning of the game
yes usually of course when a player is
thinking in move three it means that
he's not thinking about
what is the best move in that position
but obviously he's thinking about what
to choose out of the many options he
prepared at home
but i had the one one funny story judy i
had
one funny uh episode with magnus carlsen
i think which year was a 2012 maybe
in waikans there when i was black
playing against magnus and
and it took him three minutes for the
first move
to make the first move and then he
explained that he was hesitating till
the very last moment
whether to play e4 d4 and actually it
took him three minutes
uh to play d4 finally so it was quite
quite a surprise for me to see that he
comes he's sitting there
and he closed his eyes and and
you know i think like after only three
minutes he
he finally moved d4 i thought you're
going to say that
thinking about e4 d4 and played c4
no that would be my my uh variation
for him it was uh
[Music]
so so that can happen as well i i must
admit it
couple of times it has happened with me
also so
uh yeah what do you think why is that uh
actually i think it never happened with
me first of all i was playing
practically all my life e4
apart from one or two occasions by
chance
or well on purpose but i just tried it
out
but why is that that people even the
highest level
players can be somehow
so insecure with so many preparations
that you're preparing hours and tens of
hours on a specific game
possibly even in a world championship
match and then
when you are in the car and you're on
the way to the playing call you're still
hesitating
already what to do on move on it
happened first of all when you play of
course a very strong opposition it is
very important yeah the opening choice
is very important
so and sometimes uh most of the time it
happens when you are not fully satisfied
with
with uh both choices yeah you have
certain problems
or in in each case and then
or something you know all of a sudden
just before going to a game
this kind of last check and then you
find out something which is quite
unpleasant
for you and then you hesitate that is
usually the
the case i mean of course by far most of
the time you
uh you choose before and then you just
play it and
but it happens sometimes that actually
you decide at the very last moment or
even
even over the board already did it
happen to you in a world championship
match that you've decided in the last
minute
yes one yes yes and the
fifth game uh of my match with
vishwanath
actually uh there were some things
happening
and i found some hall at the very last
moment
and uh actually i when you know i
remember that i made my decision only
when the
the clock was pressed because i was and
it was the bad decision to go
again for the miranda which i lost so uh
yeah it happened it happened with me and
that's that's the the
the case i remember but probably it's
not the only one i've played after all
four world championship matches so i'm
sure
it was okay but that i remember very
well that i was you know it's all and
you know the problem is that when the
clock has started
okay if you start to sink in the world
championship match it
shows a huge huge uh
you know um
so you cannot afford it so you really i
thought okay now it's like one minute
arbiter comes they announced the game is
going to start now and i i'm just in
this
i understand that i have to do it
quickly to make my decision
and as it usually happens in such cases
you make a wrong decision yeah
so let's see what the guys whether they
made good decisions for the opening
we have the moves in the karwana game
against
ariane and it was played
just to move a few moves back that uh
well it's the classical uh rile offers
but after here of course c3 is not
played because marshall is a threat to
everybody
yeah so a4 is the most common move we
can say also d3
h3 sometimes b4 a5
and we can say actually i think that
fabiano is one of the experts in ray
lopez so for atari it's not going to be
an easy
story and he got a huge lesson by the
world champion the other day in
round 8 if i remember well i mean
so this this time there is a little
switch in the in the line
so yes c3 yeah that is i remember this
line it's uh
it can get very sharp uh in
in it's pretty direct line
i would say and there was some main line
was was really getting to a totally
crazy
complicated position uh very unbalanced
position but
frankly i don't exactly remember what
was it so ruby 8
has been played bishop c4
uh yeah this spawn on a6 this i wanted
to say that
eventually at the end of the day it
might be
a spot which uh which fabiano would like
to play for
yeah basically that's the main uh idea
of uh
white strategy in this variation because
otherwise
you know he's actually like in
development and
i'm not clear why he should even pretend
to be better so
i think that is why because this a6
weakness is fixed and
in a long run if white develops his
pieces
it will be a very annoying uh you know
annoying
problem for for for a very very long
time
so i think uh there is some now yeah i'm
trying to
to remember what was the main line i
think it was starting to be very sharp
at some point like d5 was coming in some
very very
sharp play but
frankly i don't remember exactly how was
it
but i remember that this line is quite
rare but it is
uh it is quite uh it has a lot of venom
so
uh i i i would say that better
uh better uh black is well prepared
here okay before we go on to see the
magnus's game i think we just need a
minute of technical issues so please be
patient we'll just back in a second